sinon je vous le disais tout à l'heure
l'ami michel boujenah est venu nous
rejoindre c'est sympa michel est passé
comme ça ben je me dis je rentrais de
l'image où j'ai joué et je me disais que
c'était je me suis en fait je me suis
déshabillée oui et donne les détails way
est une fois ample et amer aussi à
vendre n'ont jamais été trop tard
mais elle savait que j'étais bien aimé
d'accord elle avait senti ça fait sentir
et ensuite une fois qu'elles sont je me
suis installé dans mon livre
oui j'ai allumé la télé oui et je suis
dit bon parce que demain je pouvais pas
venir
oui j'irai à nancy demain pendant
d'accord j'ai rejoint de frédéric
mitterrand giletta ou d'accord je joue à
metz et je me suis dit c'est trop con -
de ne pas passer et de pas dire d'autant
plus que moi j'étais assez malade quand
j'étais petit j'étais très malheureux ça
fait rire tout le monde qu'il était très
malade petit jeu c'est sérieux c'est le
nerf il ya un type un jour il m'a dit
mais à taux plein que j'ai dit mais si
je m'arrête me plaindre je gagne plus ma
vie plus je me plains plus les gens ils
se marrent c'est extraordinaire j'ai été
opérée des deux bras c'est vrai si de
chirurgie voilà temime à dire c'est pas
vrai il ne croit pas c'est vrai
j'ai pas été opéré attends tu veux qu'on
aille rejoindre maxime le forestier
catherine ceylac qui ont absolument la
presse et en europe 1 de mu opération
plutôt maxime maxime catherine sur le
sort de province de paris puis après on
a train je crois que jacques était déjà
arrivé oui mais